hey man how are you
how you doing buddy good good to see you
face to face man yes sir
how you feeling i'm good man i uh you
know just
i've just had a crazy week oh yeah me
too bro me too i can imagine i've
seen you doing like the virtual book
tour yeah yeah yeah that's going pretty
well man i did uh
i'm doing two or three events every
evening which is
which on paper looks like one thing but
it's hard man
it's a grind i can imagine i mean we had
planned on before the pandemic we had
planned on having a tour
all over the country that's that's a
real grind
and so uh this is not nearly as hard as
it would have been to be
actually going to all of those cities
right right right yeah
well say i appreciate you uh tapping in
man i've been a big fan
of uh i'm a big bernie guy too so yeah i
miss bernie's uh
man i take every
i take every loss like super personally
not because of like wins and losses but
i know
the people that i'm fighting for
actually are fighting for everyday
people and i know that when when bernie
loses
or when somebody else that i'm fighting
for loses people suffer as a result of
that
and so he to me
if you went into a lab and made
a candidate designed for a pandemic
bernie would come out of that like he
was made for this moment
like i so desperately wish he was
president man
and uh he i think he would have mopped
the floor with trump man yeah it's
interesting i guess we'll just dive
right into it because like i'm
i'm very passionate about bernie and um
i was
when he lost in 2016 and there was that
moment at the
um at the convention where his brother
was crying that [ __ ] oh yeah
well you know his brother loves him man
and
and what people you know i worked with
bernie on
on this for this campaign you know
bernie
bernie was deeply hesitant to tell
his own origin story and what his
brother knew
in that moment was man they grew up
rough man like
his his family narrowly escaped the
holocaust
most of bernie's family died in the
holocaust
and they grew up dirt poor in the middle
of brooklyn
in a community of really of holocaust
survivors
and uh they both of his parents his
mother and his father died when he was
in college
and it it changed bernie in a huge way
man and when his parents died is when he
threw
himself into the civil rights movement
and um
his brother knows all of that better
than me or you or anybody
and so to see uh to see him his brother
was
was deeply touched it was a it was a
special moment for bernie who
who doesn't show a lot of his emotions
on his sleeve that's it you're right he
doesn't
yeah and to see him do that it was deep
man i'm curious like
obviously um
we are in a weird situation um you and i
as people who rode very hard for bernie
sanders and and and the ideals that he
stood up for and and
obviously it was very frustrating um
two times in a row to kind of see the
dnc like
uh it seemed like they really worked
against
him um you know
bernie he wrote he barney wrote the
forward to my book and when he wrote it
he was still running
and change which is out right now yeah
yeah and um
he says something in his forward and he
was thinking about
something else when he said this but
what we have to come to understand
is as much as the democratic
establishment
two different times conspired against
bernie
it is it's on us to
make a survey of who is for us and who
is against us and we have to out
maneuver and outsmart and out
organize them and in a lot of ways
um in retrospect after bernie was
was crushing it in the primaries
basically
and then south carolina happened and
yeah well it was not
you know he lost south carolina but
literally two days before that bernie
won
nevada in a landslide remember i
remember that yeah and caucus state that
was a caucus state right
it was a caucus state but then you know
bernie won california
typically the candidate that wins
california wins the nomination
and having won and competed in all of
the places
bernie was always in first or second and
and the democratic party basically said
listen
we need all of you to drop out we need
all of you to get behind joe biden
and we like need you to do it tomorrow
and so you saw amy klobuchar
mayor p beto and others all said okay
and uh it was too much to overcome
but but here's what bernie's talks about
in his forward man is
that instead of focusing on how they
walloped us in the future we have to
think
how might something like that happen and
how could we outflank and outmaneuver
how could we out organize something like
that
and in a way uh i don't think this is on
bernie but i think
that move kind of caught the campaign
flat-footed and uh you know
it's it's the media it's a lot of things
but at the end of the day
it's on us man if you know when if you
lose an election
it's on you you lost and uh i just
now in retrospect there are 20 things i
wish we had done differently to help
this campaign
yeah i just hope that you know he sparks
um
the next great you know politician
because his ideas obviously are
are and just his authenticity yeah and
his you know
like you said if you were to just go
into the lab and find like
a presidential candidate that would fit
what's going on right now but just in
general just like somebody who
is really a unicorn in the sense that
like they've never really switched up on
what they believe in
i mean you can cut and paste that dude
from any generation and he's bernie
he's fighting for universal health care
he's fighting for poor and marginalized
people
he's fighting for equality and access
and he's fighting against war
and you can see him doing it in every
generation
relentlessly no matter what it cost him
uh you can see him calling out you know
wealthy special interest
it can be a speech from 1979 or 2009
and it's not that it's repetitive each
time he's saying it with
passion zeal he means it every time
but i think there's a lot to learn from
that i think
a lot of up and coming politicians and
leaders that he loves
like he he loves aoc he loves
uh corey bush and jamal bowman who just
won their primaries in
missouri and new york he loves uh
jamilah
jayapal pramila jayapal rather in
seattle
uh and and a lot of others um there's
some people coming up who are
you know he loves he loves the squad and
and um
they were all members who supported him
and so um
there's some people coming up that i
think have that level of
authenticity and courage um
you know he'll continue i think he's the
type of person that will
will continue leading on the issues and
i think you'll be around you know still
for
maybe even another generation basically
what we need is
you and killer mike to run for office
somewhere
yeah right right you know i think killer
mike could
killer mike and i killer mike was born
and raised in atlanta and i lived in
atlanta for almost 20 years
somebody like him could run for congress
or mayor and he knows he knows that it's
got to happen i've talked to him
indefinitely about it and he knows that
yeah no i think not ready yet but yeah
i feel the same way you know uh i you
know i think there are a lot of things
that
he and i both would have to change about
the businesses that we run the tours
that we do
the way that our lives go when when you
are
a serious elected official most of that
has to come to a complete stop
and uh i have so many other
responsibilities
for me i tell people all the time like i
would love to run for
something local even in new york like a
city council position
what happens is people put on mike or me
or others
like you should run for mayor or
president
and there's a place for that but you
know not off the rip
is not the place yeah yeah
and so i tell people it's like no like i
actually if i'm going to do something i
want to do it well
first yeah yeah and um and and i think
that's
that shows respect for the position in
the office and
i don't see that in my future anytime
soon and i think mike is probably still
a ways away from it but
he and i both are always trying to
figure out how can we lead
with the influence and position that we
have now
well look we got sean king it's the blue
lake head podcast we've done an official
introduction we went on a bernie tangent
right away
that's my guy man um make change the
book is out
um while we're talking politics i was
very very uh
annoyed for you over this past few days
yeah that's okay it's funny because like
you said like
i feel like once every five or six weeks
you trend on twitter
yeah and for me it was frustrating
because people were putting a tweet that
you had
up i don't know during the uh primaries
it was even before the primaries it was
i wrote a tweet in 2018 before the
democratic primaries even started
before bernie had even announced and i
hadn't actually endorsed bernie yet
and sincerely i was open to endorsing
someone other than bernie and i
i said that to bernie and others that i
wanted to see who all was going to wow
and uh i just said i know two candidates
that i won't be
endorsing for that for the democratic
nomination
joe biden and kamala harris because of
their role in
mass incar in helping build mass
incarceration
uh it wasn't that i would never support
them in life or never support their
policies but i didn't
endorse them yeah they were and not even
i wasn't even talking about for
president it was
the tweet was actually in a tweet thread
people wrote
the one tweet that they tried to use
against you from this week
was was like the last tweet of like four
or five
yeah i wrote i wrote so that's what they
do so i wrote a tweet thread
that was also still very critical of
and just like i have a friend jamal true
love
and uh jamal was wrongly convicted of
murder
in san francisco a murder he didn't
commit spent eight years in prison he
was convicted by kamala harris it ruined
his life
wow and the city of san francisco had to
pay 10 million dollars
in that wrongful conviction suit and it
changed
jamal in immeasurable ways so like
as district attorney she was deeply
problematic
all i wanted people to say and then
people start saying stupid stuff like is
sean paid by the dnc
i was never paid by bernie i never
worked for bernie i was always a
volunteer
i've never been paid by a politician a
day in my life
and i've studied kamala's record
i have no desire to be buddies or
friends with her or any or
or with her campaign she's gotten
significantly better
and she's improved on issues like she
now stands against qualified immunity
for police
she's one of the few senators who who
does so uh
she now stands for the full
decriminalization and legalization of
marijuana which joe biden doesn't
and she she was a co-sponsor of a bill
with cory booker
which was probably the best bill ever on
expunging people's records who were ever
convicted in the war on drugs
and she was a co-sponsor of that bill
and so listen i know that
she and joe biden they're not my dream
come true
they weren't in my neither were in my
top ten
and yet joe yeah especially joel
and because here's the thing uh i can't
say
for joe what i can say for kamala she
has
she has evolved and improved and if
people don't want to give her credit for
that
that's more says something about them
but
joe hasn't and joe joe basically still
won't acknowledge his role in building
mass incarceration
he still won't stand for the most basic
policies that are actually popular among
democrats including universal health
care
including basic criminal justice reform
policies
and so and it's not because of his age i
don't i don't accept that
it's him i saw bernie he lacks a lot of
humility joe biden doesn't have a lot of
humility
oh he doesn't man and he he couches it
in some
other things but no no he's uh
you know he's always been that way and
um
you know i i also gave probably for the
first time in
two years i gave joe biden a compliment
in that tweet thread
to say that i was surprised that he
picked kamala
because she was the only person that ran
against him
that walloped him several she went in
on him during the the uh i watched every
debate and
yeah she she really held him over the
fire we couldn't
bernie it's not in his it's not his
style
to hit people like that right and
all of us who were in his corner wanted
him to throw
knockout punches against everybody and
it's just
he's just a good good guy
and kamala was a former prosecutor what
we were just talking about
and she hammered joe biden on the crime
bill she hammered him on his role
of between integration and segregation
and they were they were probably two of
the low moments for joe biden in the
whole debate
and um so i i said i thought it took
some level of guts for him to pick the
candidate
who hammered him the hardest one could
argue too remember i mean there was a
point in time during the primary where
it seemed like he was done there was no
money coming in and
he was close i mean he was uh south
carolina saved his ass you know
oh man and i have i have some beef with
how that happened
uh you almost aren't allowed to
criticize how south carolina
saved him because it seems anti-black or
racist
and sometimes it can venture into that
right
i just think that like bernie won
nevada with a huge
majority of the latino vote in the same
way that joe won south carolina except
bernie got no credit for it
and um i felt like both went i thought
the win in south carolina
mattered i'm not i'm not saying it
doesn't
i don't think it settled the
the campaign the guy was dead in the
water
and he literally never even campaigned
in i think
44 states didn't have any money
like for a while there he just didn't
have money nah man i i swear he probably
was doing like or
doing like uh budget rental cars man
like
they were struggling and um
i you know i had i did a uh an interview
with michael moore recently
and i i've thought about the campaign a
lot i think in retrospect
joe biden was clearly more formidable
than
than we gave him credit for
his role as barack obama's vice
president
is deeply meaningful and and
underestimated i'm sure at the
time it was and for even in my own house
like my
in most black households there's
there's you know i'm looking at my
screen here there's god here
right there's michelle obama as a little
less than god
and barack is just a little less than
michelle and then there's everybody else
and for most black voters particularly
black voters over 40
uh the fact that joe biden faithfully
served as barack's
wingman for eight years dude it mattered
to them man
and i just think we didn't give that
enough credit i think uh
bernie struggled in the south in 2016
but in this time we actually fought hard
in south carolina
what i didn't understand was
once we're kind of wonky right now but
once once uh congressman clyburn
endorsed
biden south carolina was pretty much
over and what i didn't know i don't live
in south carolina
i didn't know he had juice like that i
didn't
i knew he had a lot of influence exit
polls
showed that 60 of voters
chose their candidate in the final two
or three days which is
when he endorsed them yeah and um
so you know clyburn had everything to do
with that i don't think it's dirty
i don't think it's like listen that's
clyburn used his juice
and um we have to think like that and
figure out
how do we win and what are the path the
paths to victory
you know and uh i'm not sour grapes over
it at all
um i'm proud of how we did and
i campaigned hard in california i did
nearly 50 events up and down california
bernie won there
i campaigned in new hampshire and you
know and we
we won there so um
you know and and bernie never sold out
and uh
i just i wish there was still this
enthusiasm i have two
daughters who are 18 and 20. and this is
the first presidential election they get
to vote in
and um joe biden was pretty much
the least liked candidate among young
people for all the candidates
yeah so young people are having to learn
how old are you man i'm 33. so
i'm 40 and the older you get sometimes
you vote for people you just half-like
and that's how politics can be you don't
always get to vote for somebody that
just
blows you away right you don't even
always get to vote for people you love
sometimes you have to be super practical
about it and say
this guy donald trump is a monster
and he has to be defeated and even
though i'm not enthusiastic about joe
biden and have all of these criticisms
for me this year i'm really voting to
defeat donald trump
yeah i do think that that is kind of the
weird uh
because i've been super critical of joe
biden on on social media especially
during the primaries um
and i feel like that is the position
that people like you and i are in that
have
platforms that people for whatever
reason obviously yours is a lot bigger
than mine but people like look
look to us for whatever reason it's kind
of a weird you know
situation to be in because it's like hey
you know had maybe this not been donald
trump that
joe biden was running against like maybe
you might ride in a
a third-party candidate or something but
now is the time
no i don't yeah i agree guess what
another four years of trump
might just there the world might be gone
as we know it you know what i'm saying
here's here's the thing man you and i
have a certain level of success
and privilege and security but donald
trump
is a dire threat to very particular
communities in this country
and we owe it we owe it to
immigrants in this country we owe it to
muslims in this country and to many
other communities
to make sure that he doesn't have
another day in office
he um even his
gross mismanagement of particularly his
gross mismanagement of the of the
pandemic
i think will go down in presidential
history as one of the greatest failures
in american leadership yeah man it's not
the greatest it's one of them
well here's the thing you know we are
celebrating
now in other countries that have gone a
hundred days
without a single case and our country
just crossed five million
no i saw you post you know the rankings
of all the countries and it's
it's crazy when you look at the
countries
that are getting that are growing in the
pandemic
it is it's all developing countries
and the united states and now we don't
like to think of ourselves as a
developing nation
but we have to ask ourselves why are we
not only on this list
but we're leading the list and i just
think the united states
it's even it even gets to our health
care systems it gets into
racism and discrimination and how
inequity is built into our nation
there's a reason why we're failing
and almost every other developed nation
in the world has already flattened the
curve they're already past it and uh
there's almost no i don't see any end in
sight for us right now
yeah it's it's rough man i wanted to
talk to you because i feel like um
you've kind of become um
one of one of the leaders in this
country kind of by
by default when it comes to just
spreading awareness to what's going on
like and you've i mean i've been
following you probably for five or six
years now and
um you know i feel like what you do
is that's why i get so irked when i see
people trying to come at you i'm like
like this guy's like because you've been
around
you see more context and uh
and you also see kind of the
manipulation of
how people will extract one quote and
extract words from another quote and say
look at this guy he's a hypocrite
for me i tell you what i'll tell you
what did it for me i was
the i was the senior justice right i
moved my whole family to new york we
moved to brooklyn
and i was the senior justice writer for
the new york daily news
and i wrote hundreds and hundreds of
articles for the paper even
articles that were on the front page
articles that were the most shared
articles
in in the for the entire paper and then
i would walk around the streets of new
york this is before the pandemic
and people would come up to me and they
wouldn't tell me they read my articles
they would say something like this to me
they would say sean
uh everything i know about the news i
get from your instagram
and at first when people told me that i
freaked out a little bit because
instagram's not really built for that it
wasn't designed to be a news
source and i wasn't running my page to
be a news source
and so i i continued to write my
articles continued to push
you know push forward as a journalist
and everywhere i would go people would
say
listen if you don't post it on instagram
i don't see it
and eventually instead of rejecting that
i just leaned into it and said for
better for worse
people are using this community and
in this source as how they learn about
police brutality
about racism and bigotry and i have to
find
smart useful ways to curate this thing
better
to be responsible for it i i'm still
frustrated that we don't have better
news sources for people to lean into
where they can get
current up-to-date information on these
types of issues
but in the absence of it i just leaned
into it and just said
okay let me let me try to do better
and uh share as many stories as i can so
that's me i don't have any help
that's me you know posting them writing
them
i don't have any special apps i'm just
on my phone
chugging along trying to trying to keep
people as informed as i can
and just holding people accountable on
your page
you know i think the fact that like
i mean look as a white guy in america
who has made his
entire living as a grown up off of the
back of black culture like i've been
involved in hip hip-hop my entire life
and that's how i feed my family you know
um i got a biracial son
um and you know
like i like your page is really uh
something that like you know me and my
wife or
even my son who's 14 he follows you it's
like
well see i get that everywhere man um
everywhere that changed me too
like when someone like you tells me
that you have a child who fought
everywhere i go
i get parents who say hey my kids turn
me on to your page
or i get school teachers who tell me
elementary middle school high school
teachers say
we use your social media as a primary
source
for how we study these issues and it
just caused me to say like okay
this is uh you know social media was
kind of designed for like laughs and
giggles
it was designed for cat pictures you
know it was designed for
for uh you know uh for models
lighthearted stuff i mean yeah but you
know at the same time it's it's
also you know it's it's awareness yeah
and so i tried to lean into it man and
and so when somebody tells me
like so i don't take that lightly you
know when
when people's children or students or
teachers or professors
are using this as a source i put a lot
of effort into it
and uh and so i see it's weird as it is
and
i never imagined it would be this way
like i see the the community that i have
particularly on instagram
as being my primary way to
inform the world of injustice and i try
to give people
i try not to just tell bad stories i try
to point us to solutions
actions that we can take yeah and so um
it's uh you know you use what you have
you know and i'm i'm trying man with the
book make change
i do feel like there is a um
we got like and i feel like you do a
good job of this with grassroots law
um but i you know it's easy to post
something on instagram right it's easy
to
to spread stuff socially online um
but i don't think that's enough i don't
know if you're
truly you know obviously it helps with
spreading awareness but like a perfect
example like you know
the blackout tuesday when everyone
posted the black square
it's like okay like everyone posted that
not necessarily
just because it was the thing to do like
you look like an [ __ ] if you didn't
post the black square you know what i
mean
but what i'm curious like what would be
advice you would give
somebody who might just share stuff on
social media who doesn't necessarily
like
know how to really you know
put their put their money where their
mouth is and or take
further steps to try to make change i
know you know you can write politicians
you can call
you know all police departments and left
voicemails and send emails but like
what is kind of just some some bare
bones advice
i got you that's why i wrote the book
kev you know
when i've traveled now from the
beginning of the black lives matter
movement until right before the pandemic
i've traveled to 47 states i've been to
not just the 65 largest cities but i've
been into
north and south dakota i've been deep
into alaska
into the mississippi delta all over
texas and florida south carolina alabama
and everywhere in between
and everywhere i would go people ask me
one question they
some version of this question they would
say sean
i am i'm frustrated about injustice or
racism or bigotry or police brutality
but please tell me what i can actually
do about
it they would they would always ask me
some version of that sean
what decisions do i need to make what
actions do i need to take to
actually change this thing and it was to
answer that question that i wrote the
book
um i've answered that question in little
sound bites and in little clips
right to thousands of people but in the
book i took
272 pages to say actually let me spell
out for you
how you can use your life to make a
substantive
measurable difference i'll say two
things man
one is that most of what we do
fighting back against injustice builds
awareness
but in this and that's good you you have
very little change
without awareness but this country if
it's taught me anything
it's that it's fully willing to be aware
of its worst
problems and to do nothing about them
yeah and say
we see it it don't affect me yeah
and it's not and that's not just a trump
thing that's democrats and
republicans yeah it's a and it's not
just police brutality and mass
incarceration it's school shootings
it's climate change it's our it's our
our
horrible immigration system we know
these systems are failing
we are fully aware but being aware is
not enough
and and my book starts after awareness
so let's let's assume you are all aware
here's the first decision that you have
to make and i
i literally spend a few chapters walking
people
through how to make this decision you
have to choose a cause
and until you chew until you say listen
i'm gonna fight on this issue this very
particular issue
mine is police brutality and mass
incarceration that's the decision i made
i'm here i'm here at my house now my
wife she chose
childhood literacy she's been fighting
and working and hustling
to teach children to read for nearly 20
years now
but whatever your issue is you have to
really plant your feet down and say
i'm i'm literally not moving until i
change this
now what i say to people is it's not
enough for you to be able to tell me
well here's my issue
here's how i kind of prove whether or
not you've actually chosen a cause
it's if i ask your friends and family
hey
do you know does does kev have a cause
that he's chosen
it's when i ask your neighbors when i
ask your co-workers and colleagues
when you've chosen a cause to devote
your life to
everybody around you knows this you
won't leave them alone about it
you are constantly trying to recruit
them to it
you'd be hard-pressed to find a single
person not just in my family
but anybody who knows me who couldn't
say
yeah sean is the guy that fights back
against police brutality
it's not just because i'm well known
it's because i
i'm i'm relentless with it and the same
is true
for the most effective people in the
world
and listen the truth is it's true for
anybody who's effective at what they do
not just fighting for change it's true
for lebron with
with with sports and even getting into
entertainment it's true anybody who's
chosen their thing you know it
it's unmistakably clear and where those
people stand
like almost to a point that's how i am
you know like
i i'm around a lot of younger you know i
work in the music industry so i
i own a recording studio so i'm always
around a lot of younger younger people
and
i'm always beating them over the head
about [ __ ] and it's like
i i i'm sure it annoys them at times
most people though most people are
frustrated they're frustrated with the
world
that's that's a start but most people
haven't made a choice you know what
this is my thing i'm fighting for the
rights of girls and women
i'm fighting against climate change i'm
fighting
most people see problems and they're
angered by them they're aware of them
but change begins with making
a hardcore decision and when you make
that decision
you start to see the world it's almost
as if
when you own a car you now see that
model of that car
everywhere yeah when you make a decision
to change the world in a very particular
way
you then develop a new lens to see
opportunities to see how to solve that
problem
what i have found as basic as what i
just said is
most people haven't made that decision
and
it's why it's part of why we
see a whole lot of awareness but very
little change
not enough people have decided okay
i fought for awareness but now i'm
dedicating my life to changing this
issue
and it's it's a serious decision yo man
quick break in the podcast to tell you
about our sponsor
odd socks all right make sure you go to
oddssocksofficial.com
official dot com use the key word
bootleg calf and you'll save 20 when you
check out they got crazy licenses on
socks they got man listen
let's pull out these ric flair joints
all right they got ric flair wwe
nickelodeon
how about some chucky for halloween
coming up
or just some basic joints they got the
odd socks basics line
one more time everything you need really
you need the most comfortable socks in
the world on your feet go to
oddssoxofficial.com and use the keyword
bootleg cab
at checkout and you'll save twenty
percent off that's oddssoxofficial.com
back to the podcast um
issue i wanted to talk to you about
because i do feel like there is
um two factions
of the defund the police conversation
right um i think that
you know my my mom and my dad got into a
huge argument my my my
parents are older white people my mom's
super hippie she's like
she's really on her [ __ ] police [ __ ]
and my dad is a little less like
you're crazy right um but i think that
you know i i think that that at least
where i
stand on it is a um
i think san francisco just uh started
like
you you had posted about it again
getting a lot of my news from you yeah
san francisco just started it yeah they
just started situations
don't you don't need military you know
you don't need armed police to show up
for certain situations if a kid gets
caught shoplifting a candy bar
at a liquor store there should not be a
uh
you know three cop cars that show up and
you i mean at least you know where i
grew up i didn't grow up in great areas
so i know better than
anything no matter how small or
insignificant the call is it's always
three cop cars that show up no matter
what
yeah billy badass sometimes guns out
and they're gonna make an arrest it's
not gonna be it's not gonna be pleasant
and it could literally be over a candy
bar or a can of soda
or somebody just having a bad day at the
bus stop and someone drives by and see
like yo this guy's acting crazy at the
bus stop
but what i was going to say was i do
think that it's important that
we reform the police departments that we
have because there's so much bureaucracy
involved
and it's less about doing the right
thing and more about
all of the bureaucracy that comes with a
police department and
the unions and all that and i and i
think that at least where i stand on
defund the police
is reallocate a lot of the sources in
the same way that our um
military is over funded like grossly so
insanely right yeah like those more than
the next 10 countries combined
you know right and and hundreds of
billions of dollars
are just wasted and then the same thing
with our police departments
a lot of these police departments have
equipment that they'll never use
you know what i mean um but i feel like
i'm against just getting rid of the
police but i am
for reallocating funds
into the community from the police and
and
reforming the idea of what police are
yeah let me talk let me let me say
something about it first
your dad and most americans
are taught that police keep communities
safe
and i've done studies on this man if you
go to america's
safest cities if you go to america's
safest neighborhoods
you can hardly find a police officer in
any of them
they're safe where do you live right now
i live in i live in burbank
if you go to the safest neighborhoods in
all of los angeles
they're not swarming with police you
don't see police precincts you don't see
jails they are safe because everybody
there is employed
everybody there has jobs health care
education everybody there has resources
they are clean they are well cared for
there
there's access to there are no food
deserts there are
wonderful grocery stores there is no
lack
the things that make america's safest
neighborhoods and cities
safe aren't more police yeah and
and that's widely known if you literally
go to the 10
safest areas of los angeles you could
hardly
find the police and and here and so
that's number one
that the safest communities in america
they're
safe for very particular reasons and
what we're saying is we want to
duplicate that safety
that kind of safety in other communities
but secondly in los angeles is is
probably the most important
illustration here right now the lapd
takes up over 50 percent of of the
general fund of all of los angeles
over 50 percent of the budget
if you go to other mega cities around
the country
it tends to be between one and four
percent
in los angeles it's 51
it's so much it's so bloated that that
there's then not
funding for homelessness there's not
funding for substance
abuse and so what they do is in los
angeles and other cities around the
country
police are just expected to handle
everything
it doesn't matter if it's substance
abuse or homelessness it doesn't matter
if it's
school truancy in most cities now police
are even the
office handling pet problems and and
missing cats and dogs and it's like
listen
let's remove as much of this as police
from police as we can
number one and then another study showed
and this blew my mind even as somebody
who studies policing this was in the ap
just recently that in the average
major police department in america less
than
one percent of all of their time is
spent on violent crime
the other 99 percent is spent on traffic
tickets
is spent on unarmed non-violent disputes
it's spent on substance abuse issues
it's spent on homelessness
and what we're saying is when we talk
about defunding the police
we're saying hey let's use money smartly
on substance abuse homelessness and all
of these other issues
and if if they're only actually spending
one percent of their time on violent
crime
let's find a way for them to make that
basically their
major thing that they do and let's put
everything else and assign that
to to social workers to doctors to
nurses
and other civic groups that can handle
it
without shooting and killing somebody in
some cities right now
nearly 60 percent of all people who are
killed by police are having a mental
health crisis
um you know many people are having
either a version of a substance abuse
and a mental health crisis
and it's like listen we have problems
los angeles has problems i live in new
york
new york has problems they're hard
they're complicated
and traditionally police showing up to
the scene with guns
doesn't help any of these problems i
want us to solve them
i'm just saying the nypd and the lapd
don't have a quality track record on
solving the problems of substance abuse
and homelessness
they've been at that stuff for
generations and it's still here
let's actually tackle our hardest
problems
but do it in a way that's bigger than a
gun and a badge
and so when we say defund the police
we're saying
if cities say that black lives matter if
cities say that children matter
just make your budget say that and right
now
most city budgets don't show the
priorities they say they
have and we're saying we got to
reconsider how this works
yeah i think uh i mean you used la as a
great example like we're in a city where
really no matter what area you're in the
homeless problem is um
it's crazy it's literally it's a real
crisis
and by the way but like la san francisco
specifically right
it's a real and and my thing is to say
that when you criminalize poverty
which is basically what police do it's
like okay you're homeless we're
arresting you you have a drug problem
we're arresting you yeah you can't
criminalize
substance abuse you can't criminalize
mental health problems you can't
criminalize poverty
we have to actually treat these problems
here's the thing
these problems are expensive they're
complicated
and they're not easy solutions what we
know
is that police are horrible at solving
those three problems
and if they if they knew how to solve
those problems
los angeles would have nobody who was
homeless
because again 50 of the general fund in
los angeles goes to the lapd
yeah and so it's not what they do man
homelessness is i worked at a homeless
shelter in atlanta
and i learned
quickly that it is about the
intersection
of of poverty of mental health
of substance abuse of poor health
of unemployment and then you mash
all of those things together in one
human body and and then have somebody
that's homeless for a year or two years
or 10 years
as i lived in los angeles before too i
would meet men and women who have been
homeless
forever yeah but they're struggling with
not only deep
deep poverty they're struggling with
mental health problems they're
struggling with substance abuse and
addiction
many of them now have chronic health
problems
that even deteriorate their body and
their mental acuity
man policing doesn't salt sending those
people to jail
is cruel and unusual when they go there
that makes sense yeah
why would you put someone in jail for
using a substance well it's not only
that when you send them to jail
they are abused they are neglected they
are not
jail jails were not built to house
people
with those challenges and problems and
the biggest myth is jail like is it
there it's not there's no rehabilitation
that
that oh no no no it generally
exacerbates your worst problems and
most people obviously you see
success stories from time to time but if
you go through
the los angeles jail system you often
come out
much worse than you were when you got in
and it's uh
it chews people up and spits them out
it's unhealthy environment
i feel like what you were saying like if
the police quote unquote
just focused on violent crimes right
like hey
someone broke into my house or there's a
guy with a gun that's
trying to get into my front door or
whatever
if if you know like you said it's one
percent of what they actually do is
probably violent crimes the rest of it
is a bunch of [ __ ]
um imagine if you if if you actually
extended the hiring process the training
process
you know i feel like that's another part
of defending the police is also just
rethinking
how do we make someone a cop they should
be the hot the best of us
the best of of society should be police
officers yeah they should
not the guys who you know couldn't get
you know that i feel like a lot of cops
and this is a blanket statement i guess
i won't make it but i just feel like
in general no there are a lot of man it
um
a lot of bad people end up becoming cops
they do and honest people in the
profession i'm friends with
several brilliant kind compassionate
souls
who are currently working on the nypd
one of one of my friends named edwin
raymond
is a lieutenant inside the nypd he will
tell you
some of the worst people in all of new
york
work on that force they are now he has
he has men and women in there that he
reveres and loves
but it it attracts a certain brand of
[ __ ] and then you then empower that
person
the badge and the gun yeah to arrest
people
and give them a badge and a gun it's a
it's a dangerous
you know quotient of factors coming
together
and um and so you know the problems in
los angeles the problems in california
the problems here in new york both both
of our states are super expensive
and and these states are our states are
complicated in general
we pay a lot of taxes and but most of
that
is going to things that don't actually
solve our problems
and what black lives matter in los
angeles is saying is
no no we want to solve the same problems
we also want to be
safe we just want to go about it in a
very different way
and i also think that it's a perfect
example too where
it's not necessarily a partisan problem
because
we are a democratically rand city in a
democratically ran state and
yeah as top to bottom as is new york
yep and it's uh you know i think
you know growing up when i was like 18
19
it's like yo just democrat democrat you
know it's like
it's it you know you kind of gets
because i grew up in a democratic
household my grandma loved to build
clinton you know what i mean like my
mother was my mother loved bill clinton
as well
a long time for me to realize like the
clintons are kind of
pieces of [ __ ] kind of like shady people
man yeah
but i i feel like the same thing like we
look at a city like los
angeles where mayor garcia garcetti is a
democrat
uh gavin newsom and i i think gavin
newsom's a good dude like i feel like he
has good intentions but like obviously
he's one of the better he's one of the
better governors of of all the governors
i agree he's i think he's handled the
pandemic
well we've been overly cautious um but i
do feel like you know it's not a
partisan thing it's like
at the end of the day governing is a
hard job um
but you know i think la new york city
there's mayor de blasio there's mayor
garcetti and there's and not just that
in in in new york and california in new
york city and los
angeles our city council is completely
controlled by democrats yours is too
our state legislature is completely
controlled by democrats yours is too
and so in these states whatever problems
we have
you can't blame trump you can't blame
republicans
uh like these are our problems and we
and my thing is
oh let's own them let's figure out the
hard work
that may take the rest of our lifetime
let's figure out the hard work to solve
these problems
but it's on us and um
in these states that are completely
controlled by democrats
there are no scapegoats there are no
there are no boogeymen
it's it's democrats that control it and
so we have to own these problems
i wanted to i wanted to ask you this um
in the same way that police brutality
has always been around except for now
we have phones that can record it as it
happens right it's not like this is a
new thing this
is something that's always existed um
it's just easier to see what's actually
happening
i feel like a lot of um
trump becoming president emboldened
a lot of people who were already racist
to just be more outward with their
racism
yeah i would almost argue though that
that started when obama became president
yeah it's not his uh it's not obama's
fault
but i just feel like when the black man
became president
you s that's when oh yeah people started
to lose their [ __ ] mind and really
show their true colors
unequivocally absolutely but here's the
thing though
there's so i get that question all the
time people will ask me sean
is police brutality actually worse or is
it just
social media and technology and the
answer is well both
every study shows that police brutality
actually is
worse and we're now able to film it
document it share it tell those stories
but we have more cases of police
brutality year over year over year
we have more hate crimes in america now
than we did
five years ago and 10 years ago so hate
is rising
police brutality is rising and we have
the tools to share
and talk about it so it's not it's a bit
of a misnomer
and i hear that i heard i heard will
smith say something very similar to what
you said kev was saying like listen
we've always had these problems that's
see that is true
but the problems actually are getting
worse
it's not just that we're seeing it more
every metric and every study i've ever
seen
shows that these problems are getting
substantively worse
and and we now have the tools to be able
to tell it and share it
so it's kind of both and in that sense
that
it does feel like it's getting worse
because it is
but it also feels like it's getting
worse because we're now inundated with
information about it every single day
where do you see our country going sean
i know that um
you know all the polls are saying that
biden and and uh kamala
i mean the poll said hillary was going
to win obviously yeah
you never know what kind of tricks trump
should win they
should you would hope but what i wanted
to ask is like obviously
assuming that they win the country is
extremely divided
um i don't think that changes anytime
soon no not at all i do feel like
a leader like bernie was someone who
could talk to both extremes of the aisle
yeah and say hey look you know because
at the end of the day there are people
who voted for trump that voted for him
because
maybe they felt like they were left out
you know not necessarily
trump trump sold to to millions of
americans
i don't care what anybody says millions
of americans felt a bad
millions of white americans felt
abandoned by the democratic party
and he came in and said listen i love
you
and not only do i love you but i'm going
to stand with you i
i like you i want you to rock with me
and it was for the first
time for communities of white americans
that often voted democratic
in states like kentucky where i was born
and raised and others
in wisconsin in michigan listen he
appealed
to a level of racism and bigotry and
misogyny
no questions asked but democrats have to
own the reality
that they abandoned millions of
working-class people not just
working-class whites
but just working-class people all
together and those people have become
disaffected they've become frustrated
and and joe biden
i think a younger version of joe biden
tried to engage
that community of people in a way but um
i don't think democrats should take for
granted that they're going to win
also that none of us should take for
granted the bs that trump might pull
i i see all day-to-day stuff he's trying
to do with the post office
you know bill maher's been saying this
for a long time that like he feels like
he's not going to leave
he's like he is a he's one of the worst
human beings ever elected to to office
in this country and that says a lot
because
there's been any human beings that have
been elected kkk members have been
elected yeah and he
he's up there man he's just here he's
he's
he's so unethical and so immoral
consistently
and that i still to this day i'm having
a hard time imagining him leaving
i i just i'm not seeing it man um you
posted today that you were taking your
instagram page private i know that
you've obviously
um had a lot of death threats even i
think a few of the cops here in long
beach
were that's right yeah several current
and former long beach police officers
there was a group of
in fake on facebook right yeah 13
different police officers throughout
california
had posted death threats inside their
private facebook group but
why take your ig page private oh man
it's
i'm i'm so glad that i did actually now
there are some drawbacks that i hate it
makes it hard to share what i
what i post and i'm okay with that it
makes it hard so if you're not already
following me
it makes it very difficult for me to add
new people
but every day on my page thousands of
times a day
my page was being spammed with really
three pieces of content
like full-on spammers who were selling
products
who were actually targeting and kind of
praying even on some of the people in my
community saying like
do you need us to pay a bill follow me
and i'll help you
scammers do you need help with corrupt
with the coronavirus
follow me or people selling
cryptocurrency stuff like that so
spam now all of that is gone i hardly
see any of it
now that i've made my page private
secondly my page was being flooded with
people
who were there deliberately posting
misinformation and lies about me
every single day but what we discovered
was that the majority of the people
would post that
sometimes with fake accounts some
sometimes with accounts that looked real
but really weren't
they never followed me and when you
make your page private they now no
longer have access to that
and the third is we saw different white
supremacist groups and others
frequently planning like everybody flood
this post
flood this thing that sean just said
with
rebuttals and things like that and just
to flood up my page with misinformation
now that it's private
nobody can do that now the drawback is
now it's a closed ecosystem and i hate
that
but at least for the time being it it is
virtually spam free there'll still be
some of it
but my estimate is that probably 95 to
96
of it has already disappeared just with
a click of a button
instagram has a real problem with spam
man they do even even like you know
every time i post something it's get
your page verified or
do you need a cartoon drawing oh yeah
yeah the cartoon one is consistent man
they always get me like never go away
how many people decide cartoons
yeah yeah yeah and so no man if you go
to my post now
there nobody's selling cartoons nobody's
asking
and it just it just limited all of it so
whatever algorithms
these people are using they never
thought to actually follow
people and uh and so now i've kind of
closed the bubble at least
at least for now we'll see how it goes
um
on the light-hearted side um you know
typically we have a lot of hip-hop
people on the podcast
i know you're a hip-hop guy um yeah what
are your like top three four or five
albums of all time sean king
oh man man i would have to
you know i i was a huge nipsy fan
and i keep nipsey's last album on it's
literally
maybe the only thing that i listened to
consistently
yeah so i just so i continue to to
listen to it sometimes
the only thing i do to mix it up is like
sometimes i put it on shuffle
you know to mix the mix the order of it
up
um then i would have to go back man i
would have to go
i still listen to the stuff that i grew
up on you know i grew up on tupac i grew
up on biggie
uh i've tried to teach and share some of
that with my kids like the
uh the the edited versions but edited
old school hip-hop
they didn't edit as well it was like
reverse words
it was like what was going on anyway
yeah yeah so the edits aren't nearly as
clean man um
you know i i love the good kid mad city
from kendrick
and i still think that might be my
favorite kendrick album of all time
i mean you know what's crazy with that
uh with that album
everyone reveres that as like his
classic like his like illmatic if you
will
yeah in a way right if you go back and
listen to like to pimp a butterfly
yeah yeah aged so well with what's going
on in the world oh
absolutely no no it is so relevant for
for now
and then um man i would have to
i would have to go back man i have a
hilarious
uh story about some west coast rappers i
would i'm gonna have to come back on and
tell you this story
but uh i grew up listening to uh like
west coast rappers like sibo who was up
in
t-bone you know sibo brother lynch all
that yep yeah all
of that brother i listened to brother
lynch all of that stuff man
and uh i still go back and listen to
some of
some of my old i feel horrible when i
listen to it because
there's nothing ridiculous actually
brother lynch now i don't go back and
listen to brother lynch
when i was a kid and i heard brother
lynch i re i thought he was really out
here doing all that [ __ ] that was like i
was really freaked out
it was scary man it was on something
different like
when i was a kid we were told that he
was dead
and that uh because he was dead on the
on the album cover
and uh we were all like you know there
was no social media
and so like rumors like that could
spread and last for a
long time and then his friend x-rated
was in jail like it was
yeah that's so funny no man i never
would have taken you as a brother lynch
guy
no man we love this you know as kids now
when brother lynch first came out i was
like 14 or 15 years old
and so man you know we were just bad ass
kids man so
and so all of that stuff you know i
loved e40 and the click and
and sibo and all of that i uh i wrote a
whole chapter about a story i have with
sibo
that that's not in this book but it'll
have to be in
maybe my next book i gotta share it with
you one day man
that's fair man well listen um the book
make changes
out i think um you're a national
treasure man
and i appreciate i appreciate everything
you do and i also appreciate the way you
navigate a lot of the negativity that
comes your way
yeah thank you man um i think there's a
lot that could be learned
from the way you handle a lot hey when
did you see the andrew schultz thing he
did about you
oh yeah man i mean you know i hated that
because
you know like guys like andrew like i
like andrew
and it's like why why do that like i've
never had a
and andrew and i have several mutual
friends and it's just like
it it's sometimes it's an outer body
experience man it's
almost like being featured on snl
low-key but i do feel like there was
just so
you know there's a thin line between it
being comedy and it being like yo you're
forming like he forms a lot of people's
opinions with those bits he's been doing
yeah and um it is what it is man you
know i i see part of it as
because i'm so public at this point it's
gonna it's gonna mean that i'm subject
to misinformation
to comedy to to whatever so i don't take
it personally
i just but i do hate it because it's
like damn dude you could have literally
reached out to me
yeah and gotten better information but
his job is
his job is to kind of be a comedic
[ __ ] like i mean that
not even as an insult
and uh his shtick is to to push the
envelope
and to kind of be a hilarious [ __ ]
and he's great at what he does
it just sucks when you're on the
receiving end of it but i don't i can't
generally speaking i can't dwell on it
for long
i see it think about it and i got to
keep it moving
i see you got the uh the bulls poster
behind you
oh no no this is uh this that's boy's in
the hood oh it looks like
it's all blurry that looks like the
chicago oh you know what in fact when
okay i see what you see uh you see what
i see that looks like the [ __ ]
right there that looks like a bulls logo
right there you know what that is
that is it that says that's this poster
is like an original poster
it said it's a weird logo that says
share the dream with coca-cola
i see what you see it looks like the old
bulls logo but this is a
this boy's in the hood like there's
that's
i see the font that it could be boys
yeah yeah
sean i appreciate you man and uh keep
fighting the good fight and um
make sure you go get the book make
change amazon
did you um the the audible version you
read that like
like you have oh yeah man the audible
version is great man i narrated bernie's
on there
we have 12 different guest voices
including busta rhymes chuck diaz on
there
wow we have five original songs that are
on there
it's a lot of fun man like i don't think
there's ever been an audiobook like that
chucky and bust the rhymes on the
audiobook
yeah on audiobook and uh and and others
man we have
i think 13 different guest voices that
are on there we have original music
that's all about make change so it's a
ton of fun man
that's man amazing go support the book
um
and uh yo go get the i'm gonna i i
ordered the book on amazon but i feel
like now i gotta get the audio version
get it on audible man no you'll love it
it's it's a different we got it for
people who don't normally do audiobooks
you know so i think you'll enjoy it 100
man well look i appreciate you and uh
keep finding the good fight i'll be in
contact with you soon man thanks for
checking in buddy take care man bye now